suite à une blague polémique de jean
marie bigard dans tpm peu en février
dernier les relations avec son amie
muriel robin se sont tendu puisque
depuis plusieurs mois les deux
humoristes règlent leurs comptes par
médias interposés tout le monde en parle
c'est encore en top tweets aujourd'hui
l'origine de la dispute donc c'est une
mauvaise blague de jean marie dans tpm
pays suite à cet incident jean marie
bigard a été écartée d'un festival
d'humour le 6 mars dernier sur le
plateau de thé pmp il était revenu avec
émotion sur cette décision et que après
ça a été l'escaladent entre elle et lui
jean marie bigard va venir nous voir
dans un instant il sera avec nous
regardez jean marie bigard c'était dans
tpm pays à l'époque rien c'est que vous
êtes très pénibles parce que je suis
très peiné mais moi ce soir tu sais
pourquoi parce que je viens d'entendre
alain sang et par ces petits écriteaux
qui viennent à mon secours
tu sais quoi en quelques heures j'ai eu
un million de vues de gens qui venaient
à mon secours
voilà c'était jean marie jean marie est
avec nous ce soir
alors c'est vrai qu'on ne parle que toi
on ne parle que de ça en ce moment et
est demeuré l'europe un sculpteur si
elle pousse tous et jean marie bigard
c'est que son amie muriel robin donc lcd
seul à se désolidariser de lui en pleine
polémique pour toi jean marie donc c'est
vrai que ça tapait ni je pense regarder
me suis pris le bec avec une amie de 33
ans muriel robin donc sur facebook mais
biggar doit être puni elle a dit
paraître du mauss unit tous et moi je
lui dis mais muriel c'est pas toi c'est
pas mon ami de 33 ans qui dit ça alors
jean marie c'est vrai que ça t'a
beaucoup touché muriel robin a répondu
sur son site internet s'en arranger les
choses puisque elle a dit jean-marie
ment quand il dit que nous sommes amis
nous avons débuté ensemble et avions des
amis communs mais je n'ai pas vu
jean-marie depuis 1996 a resserré la
diarrhée depuis 23 ans ne sommes pas du
tout a mis ce aurait pu en rester là
mais le 8 septembre sur sud radio jean
marie a tenu à régler une nouvelle fois
tu es content avec muriel robin tapas
match était bon on a passé l'extrait
hier on l'expliquait même cet extrait
regarder la figure de proue du machisme
enfant un petit peu mais tellement
gentil mais tellement gentil tellement
assumer que les vraies femmes n'en
prennent pas ombrage
il n'y a que les [ __ ] qui veulent
avoir des couilles comme nous et être
aussi con que les hommes qui gueule
après moi beaucoup de soin ou muriel
robin alors sa théière et suite à ses
propos muriel a réagi muriel robin sur
le plateau de c'est à vous c'était hier
soir quand un garçon qui n'est pas mon
ami ce qu'il avait écrit sur facebook
pas le cas la dernière fois que j'ai des
navettes russe entre 4 89 cantons d'une
panne d'une déjeuner ni petit déj
pendant trente ans elle mon ami je
trouve un peu donc d'abord je veux pas
de ce qu'il dit j'en ai pas envie
je suis peut-être une grosse sigui ben
ali a le droit de penser ma forme peut
pas plaire à tout le monde mais est un
homme dit à la télé mais je veux dire la
même chose jean marie tu as une fille et
j'espère vraiment pour toi qu'un jour il
y aura pas avec ce que tu as dit cette
jolie blague garçon qui sera dit tiens
ça je vais le faire et que ça tombera
pas sur ta fille c'est vraiment tout ce
que je te souhaite parce que tu seras
trés malheur
ça a été la vidéo de muriel robin hier
donc 107 à booster un extrait est
aujourd'hui dans une vidéo publiée sur
facebook
jean-marie remet les choses au clair
avec muriel robin r non leur amitié
regarde mes relais robin qu'est ce
qu'elle dit elle dit que nous ne sommes
pas amis
je rappelle que par exemple le 7
septembre 2013
on m'a demandé avec insistance que je
fasse partie des humoristes qui te rend
des hommages 1 sur tf1 tous les gens qui
étaient cette émission était quand même
un peu tes amis si je ne m'abuse
et je te rappelle aussi il ya quelques
mois seulement 1 pas 30 ans s'est
retrouvé sur le plateau des grosses
têtes
tu as pris fait et cause pour moi t'es
dit comment commence à virer d'une
tournée tu as été tout d'un coup au fisc
et de voir que j'avais été viré d'une
tournée alors que tu as toi même tout
fait pour ça salut muriel amicalement
alors jean marie c'est vrai que bon moi
je m'entends bien que morales urbain je
m'entends très bien avec toi tu le sais
et c'est vrai que sa peine beaucoup de
monde c'est vrai c'est passe d'armes
entre vous deux parce que c'est vrai que
vous êtes deux humoristes immense et
forcément c'est vrai que ça appelle les
gens de vouloir de devoir prendre voilà
fait et cause pour l'un ou pour l'autre
jean-marie dans quel état tu aujourd'hui
ce que tu étais triste de cette taxe non
moins d'ailleurs je suis j'ai répondu à
son invitation parce que je t'adore mais
j'ai tout dit dans cette vidéo c'est à
dire elle manque a dit qu'on n'est pas
des amis
la preuve allemand voit son dvd en
disant merci d'être mon bonus c'est ce
que j'ai fait un sketch de muriel donc
comment elle peut dire que n'est pas
amis du tout voilà déjà scénarios
possibles tiens-toi des images où on
voit bien que et
donc ça c'est une première chose puis
après car quand elle parle de mes
enfants ça me touche
oui j'aime comme tulle imagine et c'est
à dire que si effectivement elle me dit
j'espère qu'un jour tu es enfants ne
seront pas dans la situation d'une de
tes blagues ce que je vois si tu vois le
contexte j'ai dit non il ya très peu de
chances pour que mon petit jules ils
soient embarqués par une chauve-souris
enragée géant
c'est un sketch et sketches et les
blagues et puis il ya la réalité et elle
confond tu peux comprendre je mérite
cette blague que tu avais fait ici quel
bac que tu as fait ça fait 20 ans que tu
l'as fait cette bague 30 ans 30 ans mais
elle est plus choquer certaines
personnes dont il réussit bien sûr la
facture ça tu le comprends mais sage
elle accepte volontiers est d'ailleurs
contrairement à l'aise à elle moi je ne
lui en veux pas tu vois moi je pense que
c'est une amie m'a jeu j'essaye de faire
rire les gens depuis 33 ans
je n'ai que qu'une seule idée en tête
c'est fait rire les gens toi j'ai pas
tué le chien j'ai j'ai insulté personne
et tous les personnages de mes blagues
sont évidemment imaginaire ya que muriel
robin qui tout d'un coup c'est dit ces
personnes n'existent avait été violée
par un médecin qui n'existent pas green
au look assez la fin de la querelle mais
honnêtement qui le premier dépasse les
limites dans la querelle c'est quand
même vous quand vous dites grosse kaunas
de nourrir roland jeanneret plaît s'il
vous plaît je veux dire le mot grosse
non mais plein kaunas
parce que je sais je sens je sens sa
grosse part est ce que je veux dire
c'est une réaction d'humeur koné sur
marie il n'y avait pas de retrait muriel
robin dis je
jean marie bigard doit être puni est-ce
qu'elle dépasse pas un peu les ailes et
pas dans l'insulté
elle réagit moi je trouve un autre la
punition des elle réagit à quelque chose
vivement mais à mon avis elle ne passe
pas les bornes
moi je suis pas daccord d'abord sont des
humoristes mais que je sois punis non
pas du tout mais quand alors ces grosses
godasses
après je pense que jean marie était
vexée qu'elle parle de ses enfants y est
mes enfants et
sata destin de mes enfants dit j'espère
que ta fille se trouvera pas dans la
situation d'un personnage d'une de mes
blagues
est-ce que là va pas un petit peu loin
on sait ce que la nappe a un peu pété
les plombs
jean masque à ce moment là et qu'il est
ce qu'elle ne deviendrait pas une grosse
conne a garanti aux le mans gosses ça va
l'annoncer on peut comprendre soit vexé
jean-marie kelly parler ça peut aller
faire des enfants elle aussi elle a été
vexé que tu la traite je pense comme ça
voilà après ces risques et mûrir ses
montées on n'est pas donnerait les
récompenses et les disgrâces l'eau
chacun faire ça à gâteau pro sans
décider qui a pété un point en premier
qui insultent l'autre en premier je
pense que aujourd'hui muriel robin
malheureusement mélange tout son combat
et son engagement contre les violences
faites aux femmes
il est noble et nécessaire il est
salvateur le feu très bien d'accord pour
le dire et on la soutient
malheureusement la cible est l'ennemi de
ce combat
ce n'est pas jean-marie bigard à ce que
je sais pas ce n'est pas un humoriste
qui fait les mêmes vannes depuis 30 ans
même si mes lire les gens savaient rien
et je voudrais dire un truc sur
jean-marie parce que jean marie
aujourd'hui tu été tirés qui auront tu
fais beaucoup de choses pour les femmes
aussi tu as tu bien sûr que tu dois là
il y dit pas tout j'en mangeais 10,1 à
mériel rebelle m'a dit mais c'est pas
parce que tu es généreux
c'est pas parce que tu as fait tu as
payé de sa poche une maternité au
burkina faso parce que 3000 femme
n'accouche plus sur la terre battue ça
n'a rien à voir
tu fais l'apologie du viol alors trois
petits cochons est ce que ce serait pas
contre les musulmans
non non mais est ce que le petit
chaperon rouge se serait pas l'apologie
de la pédophilie
non mais non mais après jean marie v
comme avec la blague la blague bolat
ondes tourne à elle était d'accord au
même pas pour dire que la blague était
été déplacée ça fait 30 ans que tu l'as
fait mais apprécierez xive et le faux
début de l'émission
ouais tu me dis tu me fais une petite
blague ouais j'ai dit je te fais
déchirure tu m'as dit parfait je savais
pas que c'est celle là en fait il a
déchiré oui
mais c'est la déchirure enfin je crois
que oui mais je sais mais bon tu vois je
savais pas que benjamin
moi j'ai la chance de connaître depuis
très longtemps et je peux attester que
c'est un garçon extrêmement sensible
extrêmement gracieux et c'est un
personnage c'est un humoriste et ça fait
30 ans qu'ils vivent csq est pas ce
qu'il fait il nous fait rire moi j'ai la
chance de voir naître des sketches quand
on fait des courses de voitures ensemble
et c'est vrai que j'ai vu moi j'ai eu la
chance d'être un peu dans ton cercle on
a les restaurants semblent et y'avait
muriel on était au cost on était au
banana c'était des grandes soirées pont
j'étais au spectacle j'avais 25 ans
j'étais vraiment j'étais face à des
grands humoristes ou je comprends que tu
sois très peiné après votre relation
était un petit museau essentielle mais
moi je voulais vivre ensemble ils vous
sembliez bien vous entendre voilà
françois viril mais mais là en fait vous
êtes victime d'un boycott vous devenez
une sorte de pestiférés est-ce qu'il
serait pas temps de passer vraiment à
autre chose passe à chaque fois vous
dommage bien sûr vous en rajoutez une
couche et vous êtes à plus encore plus
boycotter donc il faut passer à autre
chose
pas du tout à fait cela ce qui se passe
tout simplement c'est qu'elle a réclamé
que je sois punis et c'est elle qui
reçoit des pierres maintenant donc je
suis largement remboursé pour moi là
l'incident est clos et parviennent je
les dis à la fin de ma vidéo
si je t'embrasse amicalement tiger tout
vous n'auriez pas envie
jean-marie de tout réconcilier avec un
oui oui mais bien sûr je le fais un
importe quand quant aux grosses têtes je
suis l'invité mystère
oui elle reconnaît que c'est moi et elle
dit est ce qu'on risque d'avoir des mots
j'ai dit oui on risque d'avoir des mots
et elle me dit c'était il ya deux mois
ça et elle me dit mais on peut aussi se
dire qu'on s'aime et je lui dis oui bien
sûr on peut se le dire je rentre sur le
plateau elle me saute dans les bras et
nous nous embrassons comme des amies et
elle vient dire quelques jours plus tard
non c'est pas vrai alors que l a eu
tellement peur que je la déchire ce jour
là elle a pris fait et cause pour moi
dix ans mais comment comment vous a
refusé une tournée alors que c'est elle
qui le réclamaient
quand même un petit problème un
désaccord jean marie est ce
qu'aujourd'hui tu sens qu'il y ait des
humoristes des gens qui disent tiens je
vais pas je pars très content et
jean-marie parce que cette blague ça
devient compliqué
et est-ce que tu ne sont pas du tout est
ce que tu pense pas une seconde dans la
rue c'est juste pas regarder tout ça moi
je suis le mec essaye de faire la place
le moins cher possible s'est amusé à
faire à bourg et la reine je fais juste
si oui 5000 personnes à 5 euros les gens
ils sont ils trouvent plutôt que je suis
un héros et que j'essaie de venir au
secours des gens les plus défavorisés
jean marie est ce que j'espère moi que
vous allez vous réconcilier avec muriel
parce que c'est vrai que vous êtes deux
immenses humoriste avait des carrières
exceptionnelles tous les deux vous êtes
franchement des deux plus deux des plus
grands humoristes français ça fait nous
on a juste envie de vous voir vous faire
marrer ce soit toi ou muriel et c'est
vrai que ça nous a là ça nous fait chier
mais je te le dis cette brouille entre
vous deux voilà donc j'espère que
j'espère que ça va pas troubler ton
avenir voulais faire à dîner avec toi y
est les bailleurs je dois choisir est
bien sûr sans grand dommage et procédé
le mois
mais voilà tu peux l'enclencher un jeu
s'est dit affectueusement serment d
autres choix quoi donc tu penses à bien
un week end
est-ce qu'elle ne se servirait pas de la
popularité de jean marie bigard
justement pour que ça parle le plus
possible parce que s'il est attaqué avec
à quelqu'un de moins connus au moins
d'aimer mais la balle a pas besoin de ça
à valérie dans ce qu'est ce qui est ce
qui est fou c'est qu'effectivement il ya
une d'un côté une humoriste une femme
qui a vraiment pris fait et cause et qui
vraiment embrasse une cause qui est une
vraie cause noble cause mais qu'ils se
trompent de cible et la plaque quelqu'un
dont elle s'est alors j'imagine que vous
ou peut-être qu à laquelle laquelle a
zappé mais en tout cas l'a oubliée mais
on sait tous et pour ceux qui le
connaissent ou la répéter on sait très
bien que s'il ya bien quelqu'un qui
honore les femmes même si il a des 2 2
zhu de la vulgarité c'est pas quelqu'un
de vulgaire dans son âme et dans son
coeur et c'est quelqu'un qui fait des
choses concrètement aussi pour les
femmes on a parlé de cette maternité au
burkina faso qui s'appelle dénonçons ce
qui s'appelle sasha donc voilà il fait
d'être marié mais ces dommages causés
alors que vous êtes sur les matchs pause
je pense que muriel nous regardent ce
soit je suis sûr pardon je suis sûr que
muriel nous regardent ce soir
est ce que si tu avais un truc à lui
dire pour voilà essayé voilà de de voir
comment vous pourriez vous voir ce que
c'est un truc à lui dire tout lui dirais
quoi son aaa
je lui dirai muriel je t'adore tué
énormément de talent et ça me fait de la
peine de savoir que nous n'avons jamais
été amis alors que moi je les ai
toujours pensé
en tout cas moi je suis toujours ton ami
donc c'est quand tu veux bravo
franchement on n'aide pas les ça suffit
les embrouilles